[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
babe laufenberg
26 years working the cowboys radio
network as an analyst the former nfl
quarterback back on the show babe good
morning how are you
dan i'm doing great and very quickly you
know you've got your biggest fan and my
nephew kyle who lives in orange county
and california and never misses a show
and he has eaten dinner with troy aikman
with daryl johnson with jason garrett it
means nothing to him
but this means everything to him i i no
no credibility for any of that but all
of a sudden oh you're gone
[Laughter]
i'm glad to help your street cred there
babe thank you yes
thank you all right um paulie give the
poll question to babe
uh which team is
more likely to miss the playoffs the
steelers are the cowboys
to miss the playoffs
that's a heck of a question there um
i'm going to say the steelers only
because of the division they play in
where cleveland is obviously no longer a
win cincinnati should be better with joe
burrow and then you got baltimore who's
always
good and they have literally the most
difficult schedule in the nfl this year
if you base it
which is all we can do on last year's
teams and as we all know the nfc east
is so weak and i think the cowboys
offense is going to be good enough to
carry them
so i'm going to say if one of them
misses it would be pittsburgh but i
wouldn't bet on that
what would the fallout be if dallas
doesn't make the playoffs
yeah i was listening to the to the
question about mccarthy's job security
and and you're exactly right the cowboys
owner
uh he's actually pretty loyal to his
coaches and he will always tell you that
one of his biggest regrets
is firing changely after two years
and uh chang gaily actually made the
playoffs
so i i don't and i think it
all depends on how they miss the
playoffs um
of course we're in a 17 game schedule
now if they're 10 and seven and for
whatever reason that isn't good enough
to get you in or they have an inordinate
amount of injuries like they did last
year again i think you always have to
factor in
are you playing without your quarterback
i think all those things
factor in but you know no question uh
they did not sign mike mccarthy up
uh for a six and ten season last year
when did things go sideways or south
with
jerry jones and jimmy johnson
wow um you know i always
felt like the spotlight
is so big in dallas and it really is as
you well know
this this isn't a small market team
they are the most visible team uh maybe
in all the sports
and so the spotlight is big so there's
plenty of spotlight to go on
on jimmy on the cowboys owner on troy
on emmett on michael on dion that
spotlight was so big so that's the thing
that always surprised me um
but i think the other thing too dan is
when they
first united in 1989 and
jerry hired jimmy to be his head coach
the whole narrative was these guys were
best friends in college they roomed
together
they went out together and then when
they when the breakup came
it was well they only roomed together
because it was alphabetical jones and
johnson
so one minute again they were they were
best friends and the next minute they
just
happened to be thrown in the same room
but um
i i couldn't tell you exactly but
clearly they
they each wanted credit for the wins and
for the super bowls
well who deserve the most credit out of
those two
well i i honestly i think it was
i i truly believe this it was one of
those rare partnerships
and i always look at the beatles right
big music fam
and they were not george harrison was
not the best guitar player in the world
paul mccartney was not the best bass
player go on and on
ringo starr wasn't the best drummer but
those four guys together
did something that was magical and when
they split up
well they all did good work they never
did the work that they did while they
were together
so i really see that union of jimmy and
jerry just being a perfect storm
and i think they both had something to
prove
jerry was viewed as this hit coming in
from arkansas taking over the cowboys he
fired tom landry
jimmy johnson was a college coach
and what's interesting too you look at
this weekend
through the cowboys lens okay which is
kind of what i do
as the cowboys broadcaster
who would have thought the three guys
going in from the cowboys organization
right drew pearson cliff harris and
jimmy johnson
at the start drew in 1970
went undrafted in a draft that had 17
rounds
cliff harris went undrafted in 1973
again in a draft
that had 17 rounds and jimmy's first
year he goes one in 15.
so if anybody after looking at those
guys through a training camp
or their first year in professional
football pointed at him and said hey
their walks a hall of famer
you would have been you'd have been
laughed at right yeah absolutely
but here they are i actually asked mike
mccarthy that question
uh this past week i was in cowboys camp
in oxnard california where they train
and i said hey these two guys these two
players were both undrafted free agents
i said when you look out at the field
here when you go out to practice today
can you point out a free agent and say
there's a hall of famer
let alone two of them yeah well my
goodness it's just crazy
and it almost goes to you wonder how the
hell did gilbrant get into the hall of
fame when he was a guy in charge and he
drafted neither of those players
we're talking to babe laufenberg uh 26
years
uh working with the cowboys radio
network as a color and
former nfl quarterback speaking of which
your biggest concern for dak prescott
this year
is what just stay healthy
and obviously he has a shoulder injury a
strain
in training camp i'm not concerned
because they're not concerned
truly i know many times they send up a
smoke screen of
non-concern about different injuries and
then you find out the guy's out for the
year that won't happen in this case
uh i mean he has so many weapons
uh cd lamb is going to be just a great
player in this league he had
he had a really really good rookie
season caught 74 balls
but this is going to be a big time
player um you've got amari cooper
michael gallup you got zeke elliot who i
know
i think much like mark twain reports of
his death they've been greatly
exaggerated
he's a heck of a back and he's he came
to camp he weighed 218
which is lighter than he's ever been
maybe a little too light quite honestly
in my book because he's a big powerful
man
what about the defense though put some
points up yeah that's
they were they were literally
historically bad last year
uh i i always like the bob dylan line
just when you think
things have gotten as bad as they can
they get a little worse and
so people say well it can't be as bad as
last year i always said well why not
there's there's no rule that says okay
if you're really really bad
you will not be worse but they did try
to address it obviously in the draft
first
six draft picks were on defense and
uh so they should be better it appears
they've brought in
some pretty good veteran guys that are
going to shore things up a little bit
um but yeah so
i mean they should be better but there
are no guarantees as you all know
but i do think that the offense is going
to carry this team if the defense can
just be
average they're going to win a lot of
games
well it it it's like the kansas city
chiefs created this model that they're
just going to score all these points and
then you just ask your defense
to come up with a couple of big stops
and yeah
and that's what they did in the super
bowl they won chris jones came up with a
couple of big plays
and uh and that's it i mean you can
score in the nfl but everybody scores
really what separates it feels like babe
is the team that does
you know tampa won the super bowl
because of their defense not because of
their offense
well i'll say this so now the last five
super bowl winners have all had top five
scoring offenses so you've got to be
able to
score points in today's nfl and
obviously they make it easy for you
i don't say easy it wouldn't be easy if
i was out there but
they've made it a lot easier that uh you
know
the days of you know winning games 13 to
six
um those are those are gone so you got
to be able to score points i even saw
nick saban
uh was listening to him he talked about
the fact that
the one year they gave up 9.9 points a
game
they they allowed 63 rushing yards
a game he said i was always play defense
you know run the ball
and he said once they started throwing
around they started winning more games
and winning by bigger margins
so if nick saban can
change his philosophy if you will now
obviously he still wants to play defense
and they've got about 10 first rounders
over there
this year probably to do it with but you
know
it's just be that's just the way the
game has evolved and become and
again a lot of the rule changes um as we
well know are all geared to offense
and you you're keeping quarterbacks
around longer because you can't hit him
ben roethlisberger tonight i mean
he won't play tonight but you know 18
years in the league
thinking about playing next year so we
see the longevity of these guys
really lasting because they're not
taking the beating that they once did
before i let you go when you were at
stanford
and you got there i think the year
before john elway so
elway comes in when did you know your
days were numbered as
a quarterback at stanford when elway
showed up
i think it was the
second half hour of the first practice
so the first half hour was okay it was
the second half
yeah but all we did then was stretch we
were doing some stretching and
drills actually you know interestingly
enough i played against john ellie in
high school so i knew
i knew how good he was and uh of course
you know you think you're gonna compete
but uh
but yeah he was pretty good and the one
good thing about that then when i when i
left stanford of course immediately
people think oh you flunked out i said
no no no no
but i always tell people look if i was
smart enough to get into stanford i was
also smart enough to know when to leave
when i always showed up i said you know
this doesn't look so good for the
bambino here
uh how would you describe him for those
who
who didn't see him when he came in at 18
19 years of age
uh he i mean he had the same arm that
you saw as an nfl player and again i
actually saw
in high school uh what i think is funny
is some of these guys have really smooth
motions right and the ball just kind of
said wow where did they generate that
power every time he threw
i swear it looked like he was going to
tear his rotator cuff you can just
picture him can't you yeah
in the pocket on his toes chin up
and then he just ripped the ball but uh
never forget to like two practices in a
guy ran a hook round at about 12 yards
and
literally just tore the receiver's
finger
straight off straight back phone out oh
wow
yeah that's at first i thought you know
guys really
liked to catch my ball when i was there
we were competing at stanford there and
then i realized you know what they
really just don't like to catch john's
because it comes in about 100 miles in
our mind
you know i always like it when they say
this guy throws a catchable ball that
means he's got a weak arm
right and many times the problem is it's
catchable for the defense
this is usually for the office uh have
fun tonight babe i'd love to
check in with you uh during the season
and uh thanks for joining us
yes sir my pleasure thank you dan
appreciate it that's babe laufenberg
26 years working with the cowboys as
their color analyst on radio